I wonder what number thumbnail I am of a
critic who's reviewing this movie and
makes this ma thumbnail I guarantee you
there's gonna be a lot of those either
that or in really angry faces I actually
don't think this is warranting of like a
really angry face uh I'll just say right
off the bat um I don't think I was gonna
say x-men Dark Phoenix but it's not that
it's just dark Phoenix you don't even
need x-men anymore I guess I don't know
but I don't think dark Phoenix is as bad
as everyone is saying it is I didn't
hate it I think there's one or two kind
of entertaining moments it's usually
shot pretty nice there's an occasional
creative action moment not an entire
sequence but an action moment and it's
still not good it's it's a bad movie I'd
say okay so when I saw the trailer for
this movie I really thought like man
this is gonna be this is just gonna be
another generic x-men movie where they
started to get like away from that with
first class we really started to bring
like this new life into it and then they
brought singer back and they started to
go can the old-school x-men movies which
I aren't awful or terrible or anything
they're just it kind of bland and I feel
account-book movies are really come a
far way I think those are steps
backwards and and now we have this one
which is I mean yeah it feels like
another step backwards um but but at
least it stuck more to the comics unlike
that awful you know last stand because
that uh yeah that that was just terrible
compared to this no energy or fun or
creativity or ideas at all could compare
to this they follow the comic closer so
it's good okay I'm sorry I go on and on
about how last Aang is way too much shit
compared to all the Erickson movies
that's come out it is looking better and
better isn't it but I get people who
don't like it I IVA sauce by it but like
x-men movies in general because I love
the x-men
I loved the cartoon growing up I loved
doing the comic i I just lost this
incredible energy in color and like I
said just cool ideas and this one is
very colorless the acting is kind of
bizarre because there's it's not quite
laugh-out-loud bad though there are some
times most of them belong to Jennifer
Lawrence but but there definitely are
times where the acting is just so
awkward it did make me giggle but it's
not the majority the I'm watching this
I'm saying why isn't what's wrong with
the acting in this because like if I was
on set and just listening to him talking
okay that's a good job uh but something
about it all together wasn't clicking
and I think I figured out what it was
everyone has this it's not quite
monotone it's kind of like a few steps
above monotone but but but it's not that
guy I've seen actors that do nothing but
monotone and they're boring and they're
not interesting and these actors aren't
really doing that but there is sort of
like there's kind of like this beat that
it follows and it never really changes
it's like everyone plays this one note
of acting that in a good symphony those
would be good notes but when it's just
this one note it gets pretty dull not
surprisingly the way everyone talks it's
kind of like this with these pauses in a
way it's kind of Shatner ish but every
once in a while when you're emotional
you might raise your voice a little bit
like this so you see you're listening
but now you're starting to get a little
bored of what I'm saying and the way I'm
saying it it's that tone throughout the
whole thing which don't get me wrong
people when they're in you know with
something really dramatic is going on or
they need to really make a point if they
can talk that way that there's kind of
that
I ate power that you can bring but again
it's kind of like hearing a nice little
melody and that melody just keeps
repeating over and over and over there's
no variation that's kind of what the
acting is like so I kind of feel bad
because I don't feel that's necessarily
the actors fault I feel that it is kind
of a directing thing where you know you
need to mix it up there could be a bit
more smiling in this movie and I know it
sounds weird cuz it's dark because
that's the only Phoenix there is you
know there's never any other type of
Phoenix
you know personality or anything that
ever happen it's always the bad dark one
but yeah I feel like even in you know
you look at something like endgame which
god is that like just long and drawn-out
and dramatic and set but they still tell
a few jokes they still get a few laughs
and smiles and you know there's some
times I try to find the positive of
something terrible that happened and
this just seemed like once it got even
when things are good they're miserable
like the movie opens up with the x-men
it's a little weird but at the same time
like I'm kind of open to this like the
x-men are now like kind of seen as
superheroes it takes place in 1992 which
is really weird because that's when the
x-men cartoon came out and this really
isn't at the x-men cartoon but the the
everybody accepts them there's like this
kind of like the Batphone except for the
x-men where the president calls it just
that's a big excitement but I'm kind of
open to that cuz at least it's a bit
more comic book II I mean it's silly but
it's like it's like all right I don't
know if that's x-men but at least it's
kind of comic book ish and and everyone
kind of loves them there's little toys
made out of them and everything so
things have apparently really come a
long way and I think you know by now you
don't even try with a timeline I'm Amy
it's just ridiculous I mean how many
years until think I look like Patrick
Stewart it doesn't make any sense but
and they they go into space they go
pretty quick into space
and you know a night crawler has to zap
across space you know in from one
shuttle into the other the Blackbird and
KITT now go into space and everything
and it's it's silly but I'm kind of okay
with it cuz I'm just like okay this is
at least going a few extra steps from
what we normally see in these x-men
movies you know it's kind of having fun
it's feeling that it's feeling
comic-book ish um but then after this
giant of fire beam whatever goes into
gene which I somehow she can breathe in
space I totally didn't hear how because
like was it Quicksilver his name uh uh
whatever he's called he makes like this
fast little duct tape astronaut outfit
for Nightcrawler but then Jean Grey's
like I'm fine like hi I totally missed
that but but you kind of know this if
she gets kind of fantastic Ford into
this we're like the giant fire beam you
know light like hits her and like it
turns her into the Phoenix which is a
nickname again and even that doesn't
totally make sense because at the end of
apocalypse they show her like shooting
out the fire bird which is like well
okay so they're doing this thing again
where it's not gonna be aliens and now
and this one it's like no no it is
aliens well what's the Firebird thing
before but anyways so after that it just
kind of goes pretty slow but not too
like for me not quite aggravatingly slow
because I was with it okay it's just
that acting kind of finally just drains
you like I said I mean you're just like
okay it's just kind of this way of
talking throughout the whole thing and
there's no variation and it gets old
after a while
and if they do stick why Wednesday it's
100% faithful clearly to the comic they
stick closer to what the Phoenix is that
it is you know this alien force there
are aliens that come down and try to you
know take control of it she I guess just
the regular good Phoenix or whatever you
want to call it feat Phoenix is a
complicated story but anyway
but you know she starts off I guess okay
and then goes crazy pretty fast and I
guess it's supposed to be like a White
Queen comes in and but she's an alien
now and there was a white queen like in
first class too so it's really confusing
they never call her white queen but it's
like that's white queen in the comic
right that was like trying to take
control of her and trying to mess with
her mind and everything but anyway so
this alien wound comes in they want the
power for themselves and it's just kind
of watching gene go nuts and go why did
I go nuts and then she goes nuts and why
did I go nuts and it's just got that
over and over and the big problem is
like even though I always kind of made
fun of the x-men movies for acting like
they have a lot of character there but
they really usually don't it's usually
like just enough where I'm interested
where with this one they're really
trying to do like this big dive into
Jean Grey like really make her
interesting and she's always been the
most boring character the only thing
interesting about her is that she's the
Phoenix I get why she's there you need
her I mean she's like you know the
second banana to Xavier and she's kind
of like the she's kind of like the
counselor that everybody can talk to you
know kind of thing and you need that you
need the kind sympathetic you know a
grounded mutant which is really great
but everyone wants to do the Phoenix
story and now you fear just dark Phoenix
where she goes crazy because they think
it's like this really great story and
it's like it's good it's big I think
that's why everybody wants to do it cuz
I mean worlds get destroyed in galaxies
and like whole civilizations get
destroyed you know just because the this
force inside her head goes nuts and
she's usually seen as this very you know
nice kind character but it's kind of
like its equivalent of like doing Star
Trek The Next Generation movies and just
putting all the focus on counselor Troi
it's like why like she's fine she's
needed I I mean she's
she's a decent of character but like
it's like no no not Picard not data not
war but ROI
we got really make a lot of movies about
Troy and it's like why if that's what I
feel like whenever they do anything with
Jean Grey the Dark Phoenix and if I'm
right I think jeans only been as the
this version of jean has only been in
one movie I think she's only been in
Apocalypse maybe she's been like teased
before but it's like we've only seen her
a little bit in Apocalypse and even then
it's not much I may be cut because it's
Jean Grey she's not that interesting
she's either the trophy between like
Cyclops of Wolverine or she's you know
like I said the grounded mutant that
goes crazy because she was Dark Phoenix
oh I don't get why they keep coming back
to this I think it was just their way of
saying hey we made up for you know last
dan which good job I'd rather watch the
last day in anybody look at this
I think of rather I don't think this is
the worst one III think origins is worse
I think in terms of watching uh it's not
a worse movie but I owe it stuff
whatever rather watch this over the
Wolverine I don't know the Wolverine is
not that bad a movie you could even
argue at you it's a very decent movie
it's just kind of dull but but it makes
more sense than this I like for example
you know storm is in this movie - again
I think she comes in Apocalypse but it's
like okay so she controls the weather
and that's about it and again - like the
original x-men's credit even though I
think they gave her more character
because it was played by Halle Berry and
she turned to a big star they did tried
to give her more credit and they're just
they're playing off this movie like
you've known these characters forever
and you really haven't you've seen
different versions of them in the early
x-men movies but we haven't really set
up this storm that much or this gene
that much or the Cyclops that much you
know and you're missing a lot of the
crowd favorite you're not gonna get you
know Wolverine and there
not gonna get gambit in there I mean
you're not gonna get rogue in there I
mean the ones that people really like to
see so you're kind of getting the ones
that like you're getting the trading
cards that nobody minds losing
it's like a whole x-men movie of Trading
Cards nobody cares about like oh you
want Wolverine idea Gina I'll give you
g4 Wolverine cuz god I want Wolverine
you know or gambit or any of them so and
so that's kind of the main problems that
the movie is playing it like we really
know these characters and even when
they're trying to take time to set them
up well particularly gene that's
arguably the only one they're trying to
set up she's just not that interesting
and it's still like I said that one note
acting the other thing that's kind of
odd like because I love James McAvoy
he's one of those actors that can do
very little wrong to me I can kind of
sum up his acting in it kind of one
weird delivery like his whole
performance is kind of like what like
that that's kind of his thing like it's
not quite Mark Wahlberg what no but it's
kind of like what like that's kind of
his thing throughout that it's kind of
like a jerky shrug that's what the whole
performance feels like like it says
somebody this isn't really a spoiler I
won't say who she can't figure it out
pretty easily but somebody dies in this
movie and this is supposed to be like
hitting him very hard and somebody else
is really angry about he has to talk
with him and if the whole thing is just
like what we talking about what come on
and it's like he just lost like a dear
friend in this and he's just acting like
it's dumb stupid you're stupid like it's
very bizarre so and it's not necessarily
what he's saying but like his
performance comes across like that half
the time and I'm wondering part of that
is the editing too because a lot of the
editing well I don't remember being bad
or anything there are times where like
you see the the black bird it's landing
droom there's smoke and everything zoo
just cuts to them walking out like
there's no more smoke no more shaking
the sounds go on like it was a there's
little scenes like that to like this
explosion will have
in a train and somebody turns and all
Sun just all the bad guys are lined up
inside and there's no smoke or anything
there's kind of weird edits like that so
I'm kind of wondering if maybe some of
these scenes will play better if some of
the editing if they were expanded a bit
more but I don't think so cuz like I
said there's so little variation and how
they're acting if there's another
strange scene where like a night crawler
one scene which again I think he came in
in Apocalypse oh we don't know him that
long he had very little tension
apocalypse aside from you know just
using his powers there's one scene where
like he tries to save someone that he
can't and he just goes just like I guess
goes nuts and starts killing a bunch of
these you know people you know the bad
guys which at first I'm like well okay I
a I don't know Nightcrawler that well in
this universe whatever you're doing with
him and be like the Nightcrawler I
remember was like super religious and
didn't want to kill him bite thing you
want to hurt anybody
so this seems kind of out of left field
so not only have you not established who
this character is in this new universe
but also doesn't match the other
universe that set them up before so
that's a huge problem
it can't feels that way with most of the
characters I they just feel like we've
because there's been some a x-men movies
and we've seen a version of gene a
version of Cyclops a version of beasts I
always seen beast a little bit I'll say
the people that we've seen more than one
movie on they're basically the most
interesting because we got to know them
a little bit too you know this magneto
we've got to know this Xavier and this
beast but all the other ones I mean
we've had a movie and they didn't really
dive that much into him so it it just
there's no connection with them uh but
with that said I mean there's still one
or two cool scenes of Phoenix doing some
cool Phoenix things you know blowing
shit up and and acting crazy
once in a while is a real bad delivery
acting wise and like I said a lot of
them are from Jennifer Lawrence I
remember everyone said like in
Apocalypse she was really really bad and
I
I've only seen Apocalypse once big shock
but I don't remember her being that bad
but but maybe that's just I was
distracted by everything else because
everyone said oh she's so bad in
Apocalypse but but I missed it may I see
it again she's bad here like she is just
this is what's my contract all right
this guy view last one right it's gotta
be that's what and the dialogue in the
movie too sadly is just written for like
an asshole like me to make jokes about
because it's stuff like magneto see yes
Charles things always go wrong is always
an apology there's always a speech and
nobody cares and I'm just like yeah
there's a scene at the end where it's a
again the x-men are heroes at the
beginning of this at some point they're
arrested and one of the guards is like
my kids used to be such a fan of you and
it's like yeah there's a the whole
ending honestly again without gang and
spoilers is kind of building up like
yeah the the x-men are gone and I'm not
gone it's just a new beginning or
something and it's like Disney just
bought Fox so please start this over
please let this be the last one of this
whatever you want call it singer
universe I mean like half of them the
cool ones are gone Wolverines gone
gambits gone oh I me and I could bring a
bag rogue was botched you know so it's
like I saw you doing fantastic for Dax
know you're redoing that let's get x-men
going do a TV show like Jessica Jones or
something like this you can spend even
more time with them just do something
really cool shit just yeah let's let's
stop this universe man and everyone kind
of acts like they're just they're kind
of done even people who it's like it's
only their second movie there's not even
that many new mutants in this that's one
of the things you always to look forward
to with these x-men movies is what new
mutant are they gonna show but they've
either you know already use them and not
very well like got how cool would be the
you know how cool would have been to see
Bishop you know actually be bish
but you know we just get a little sneak
preview of him and Days of Future past I
like there's all these cool mutants you
can use so they're either out of them or
they just have the ones they have now
they're not really established yet at
least not in this world so they have to
try and give them some attention they're
not that good at it so but with that
said anytime there's like an action
sequence when it's not shaky candy you
know they do a little bit of that and
they got some cool scenes that anytime
magneto does something it's cool anytime
a mutant kind of needs to look cool they
make them look pretty cool
whenever somebody flies in it's like
alright that's neat then going into
space and doing the space stuff it's
candy you know every once in a while it
kind of feels like x-men which again I I
like seeing I like seeing you know more
that color in there it opens up with
them and sort of the bright yellow and
blue outfits and they're going to the
black bird and they're gonna go into
space and I'm like okay this you haven't
set up much it's pretty silly but it's
like alright at least some at least it's
feeling a touch like x-men but yeah that
that's about it in terms of like that
much of a connection to like the
original source material you know they
do have it where it's aliens great but
but gene is still boring the aliens are
boring and the closest thing to
interesting outside of the way it shots
sometimes an occasional action scene is
is the actors we've actually gotten to
know you know at G's McAvoy and so forth
you know are doing they do okay
but as they themselves acknowledge as
their characters they've just done this
a million times now it just feels old it
feels stale but like I said I can't say
any of it feels really half-assed and
there's some movies where you can feel
that or they just feel so lost and they
don't know what they're doing and I feel
like now this director had an idea and
he was trying to you know bring the big
screen version of this and and it didn't
work it was not a it was not an
interesting vision I can't even say it's
like a terrible vision
it's not it's competently done its you
see the trailer if you're like oh I want
to see that most likely you'll get the
movie you think you're gonna see um but
I don't know what you want I wanted to
see this movie everyone I saw it's like
oh this again are they still doing this
and yeah everyone kind of has that feel
to them like you know yeah what we're
gonna do it we're gonna be professional
but yeah there's nothing new here right
there's like nothing interesting left in
this universe like that's kind of the
feeling that you get from it so um so I
feel like that they're trying but
they're like there's nothing here
there's nothing to do so yeah I I don't
hate this movie I just think it's not
very interesting there's one or two cool
moments where I'm like alright that's
neat but even like a big Quicksilver
scene like you know he has a few scenes
in the opening and he just kind of
vanishes I think he gets hurt like like
he trips and then you see you there Lee
he's like in a stretcher but he's still
like blinking his eyes I mean he's still
like hey I'm here and then we just don't
see him I don't know they couldn't like
get him for the rest of the movie he had
to like shoot another movie or something
like that but he has like a one-second
appearance at the end and he's like the
one thing that everyone loved in all
these new movies so yeah that's the
that's about it if you're looking at the
trailer and you're just like I'm
probably not gonna like that you're
probably not gonna like it
the trailer is actually a very good
indication of what you're gonna get
you know if you want to see Michael
Fassbender - I'll say this he like he
and the effects people and the
cinematographer had totally recreated
what it means to walk away from an
explosion without looking at it cuz I
feel like in every movie he does
something cool and he doesn't look back
like you know he'll be walking all these
people who guns him he just goes like
this and they all go flying like well
he's why in this one he's walking in
while a train is like you know crashing
into a door behind him and he's
controlling it so the blocks
like he's I feel like he's recreated the
explosion without looking back at it you
know so once in a while there's a little
cool scene like that I'm like re that
was need and there's very few moments
where I was actually like oh that's
stupid
oh that's terrible um it's just not that
fascinating it just seems like there's
nothing new left so I really feel like
this franchise needs to be scrapped
you're done and go ahead start it over I
don't think it's the worst one I think
you'd argue like I say x-men origins is
worse I think you could argue apocalypse
is worse gaff the hell were even the
other ones like I say I don't know if
everyone watched this over the Wolverine
because the Wolverine is actually no I
drove over Ian over there's more thing
about it that would like the the culture
and the shots and that little psychic
yeah with a red hair like she was cool
I'm like yeah you might guys see that
movie again actually maybe it's better
than I remember being a boring but yeah
that's um that's about where I am with
the x-men movies now at Dark Phoenix I'm
I'd be fascinated to see if this did
well box-office wise cause it's getting
trashed by critics and everyone I've
talked to is just like they're done with
these x-men and maybe that's the
attitude I went in with this too and so
I set the bar so low that just like what
I got wasn't awful I don't think it was
terrible but but it's it's not good it's
not a good flick so um yeah that's my
take and I will see you next time take
care
you